you're welcome gnarly Salmons didn't a
press conference on Davis Cup recently
eras various Rick spanks please
economist via tins got till alfred
nobel's mean effort for tues and few
tomm welcome to this press conference
where we shall soon present this very
serious Bank prize in economic sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel for 2014 we
will keep to our tradition and start in
Swedish and then continue the
presentation in English and later on
you're welcome to ask questions in
either language yah yah here Terry
Stefano Marcus then the Secretary have a
clear vision scope z'ha'dum in Omaha may
have reported hi professor Thorstein
passions my secretary the economy please
comedian or professor to mature strim
oak professor today Ellingson smile for
and the economy please committee on the
young Loretta's cops academy o dos cast
xperia tamil eesha tumblr your or its
economy please holler Oh Matt tiglah
McTeague afford awk kungliga beaten
scoffs academy in habilitative de las
very sick spanks please economic spirit
and scope till alfred nobel's min node
for to serve you until professor gentil
role university of toulouse capital
frankly key academies motive earring
leader ferns annalisa mark not
smack-talk rig leering this year's prize
in economic sciences is about taming
powerful firms the royal swedish academy
of sciences has decided to avoid this
very ascetic spank prize in economic
sciences in memory of alfred nobel 2014
to Professor gentil role to lose one
capital universe
city France for his analysis of market
power and regulation so professor to
railings on will now give us a summary
in English please thank you Stefan is
this on it it's all know if you like
large firms are important usually size
is a sign of economic health firms grow
large if they perform better than their
competitors and as a general rule we
should encourage the flow of resources
away from small and unproductive firms
toward larger and more productive ones
only if our firms are productive can our
wages and our living standards be high
but not all large firms are productive
in some cases firms are large and
influential because the production
technology only leaves room for one firm
a monopoly we would not want to have
several different railway tracks between
two cities we would not want to have
several sets of water pipes into our
houses and it's enough with one local
electrical transmission network these
monopolies don't dominate the market
because they are productive so the first
question is in the absence of
competition how may we encourage such
producers to be productive in markets
that are not natural monopolies firms
usually become large because they are
productive this is the bright side of
profit seeking but firms sometimes
remain large because they are cunning
large firms may abuse their dominant
position to block competition from
newcomers with better ideas that is the
dark side of profit seeking thus our
second question is how can we best
prevent the abuse of market power
and finally of course there are many
industries with several large firms or
third question concerns that complicated
case how do we make sure that there is
adequate competition between these
oligopolies with help of a branch of
mathematics known as game theory shanthi
role has been thinking through these
questions more deeply than any
economists before him and as a
consequence many different industry
regulators as well as competition
authorities all over the world have
obtained a whole new set of tools let me
give you your just a tiny taste of how
the game theoretic revolution has
affected our thinking about regulation
and competition policy 30 years ago
monopoly regulation predominantly meant
capping the monopolists profit a regime
known as rate of return or cost of
service regulation cost of service
regulation makes sense from a
distributional point of view no
monopolist is getting rich from
producing the goods and services that we
all depend on but cost of service
regulation does little or nothing to
contain the producers costs or to
encourage quality improvement indeed it
was widespread dissatisfaction with high
costs and low quality and regulated
sectors that triggered the wave of
deregulation in the 1980s the challenge
of designing better regulations was
taken up by jean tirol and his co-author
jean-jacques l'iphone who died
prematurely a decade ago together they
published a series of influential
articles about regulation theory and
according to them the regulator's main
problem is asymmetric information about
opportunities that is the regulator
knows much
about the scope for improvement then the
monopolist does so you see she's
blindfolded up here however the right
response is not to apply cost-of-service
regulation everywhere instead
cost-of-service regulation should only
be applied to those producers who claim
to have little scope for improvement
producers who claim that they can do
better should be offered a share of the
added value that they generate but such
sophisticated regulation is tricky due
to a second problem the problem of
limited commitment an efficient producer
may rightly be afraid of being exploited
in the future the regulator could say oh
is that how efficient you are please
hand over some more of your surplus this
is known as the ratchet effect since
requirements only ratchet up and never
slide down I think anyone who has made
large purchases at the end of a budget
year in order not to have the budget cut
knows what I'm talking about such
commitment problems on the regulator
side will discourage the firm from
revealing its true productivity and as
lawful anti-roll showed strong
incentives no longer work so well their
work collected and extended in their
1993 book develops in much more detail
the nature of optimal regulation of
monopolies under asymmetric information
and limited commitment it also sheds
light on many other related problems
ranging from the optimal internal
organization of firms to issues
concerning privatization and public
procurement but in the interest of time
let me skip quickly to questions 2 and 3
in most industries the government does
not regulate individual producers
instead competition legislation
restrains powerful firms from excluding
their rivals and from exploiting their
customers but how should these
competition rules be formulated in the
1970s many economists were still looking
for general yet precise legislation that
would apply equally to all industries
but as these economies were reasoning
without the help of a rigorous formal
framework it was all too easy to
overlook complications and jump to
conclusions for example the conventional
wisdom was that cooperation between
firms in the same market segments so
called horizontal agreements are always
bad whereas cooperation between firms in
successive segments vertical agreements
are always all right to the contrary
shanthi role and his co-authors showed
that vertical agreements have
significant significant potential to
harm competition whereas horizontal
agreements sometimes have the potential
to be useful for example in the case of
patent pools but most importantly all
industries shouldn't be treated the same
the best regulation of the
telecommunications industry is not the
same as the best regulation of the
banking industry now that may sound
trivial but the beauty of Tyros work is
that he has been able to describe deep
and essential differences between
various industries and to show just how
regulatory policies ought to respond to
those differences as it happens frontier
role is not only a star theorist but
also a great expert on many industries
including telecommunications and banking
so it is with great enthusiasm that the
royal swedish academy of sciences has
decided to honor the monumental
contribution of one of our greatest
living economists thank you so much
Thank You professor ellingson I think we
have professor to roll with us on phone
from to loose in France Bonjour
professor Eon congratulations right now
I'm sitting here in the session hole at
the royal swedish academy of sciences we
have a press conference here and many
interested journalists from Swedish and
international press or you ready
professor tirol to to take some
questions from them sure I thanks so
much for some very honored and I'm
willing to take questions also I'm so
moved that this may not be the best man
to answer questions that I'll try okay
here we have the first question mr. to
all I supposed to people all over the
world are googling your name right now
so I have a question that can you answer
how is the best way to prevent companies
like Google to misuse the position well
we have been working on what's called
two-sided market and try to understand
how they will function and how to
regulate them possibly so two-sided
markets markets where you need to
attract both sides of the market so for
example for Google you need to attract
what's called the eyeballs people were
going to go to the website and the
advertisers and many many such markets
have the specificities and any kind of
platform create cards also payment cards
are the specifics didymus attract
emergence
and also card holders and so on and so
forth what we have shown is actually
that the antitrust economics are such
markets are different from the sort of
market so for example often your prices
which are way below cost actually if you
think about Google you as a customer you
get a very good deal you actually get
for free and on top of that you get all
those services with email and search by
contrast advisors are going to pay quite
a lot the same is true also for payment
cards where the merchant is a lot and
the cod orders gets lot and that raises
issues with competition policy but not a
solid issue about predictions tradition
means that you are pricing below
marginal cost or even with monopoly
pricing so there are different issues
now it's it's clear that in such
industries by the way you just tell me
if I stink I'm speaking too fast with
emotion it is clear that with such
industries that the network
externalities are very strong so you're
a tendency toward monopolization such
monopolization is not dangerous as long
as there is a possibility of entry so
having a temporary monopoly can define
that you need to have possible entry
contest what we call in an industry
organization contestability so that more
dynamic firms can replace incumbent
frame and the antitrust authorities have
to be careful with that but the message
I want to send is that with those two
sided markets are the messages for
competition policy yeah I'll be
different than the standard ones for one
sided markets which we are in dealing
with see in the late 19th century okay
do it thank you very much do we have
some more questions to to Professor
tirol
there hello professor the dis assuming
full from China's national news agency
first congratulations regular to your
achievement and I would like to to give
some brief comments on the banking
industry as for given the current
international situation in this economic
crisis and recuperating in the field of
banking industry what do you think via
current authorities could learn or could
drawn from your theory and apply them
into practice and bring us back to
normal thank you I think banking is a
very odd thing to regulate than we have
we economies academics have to do more
work on this varun for example we have
been working for a long time in
particular ways I've been working with
my casa bank Tom storm and also within a
nursery on issues having to do with
maturity mismatches you know in equality
and maturity mismatches and now the
authorities are putting in place some
recognition of liquidity which is a very
good thing but the details of which we
haven't been very much working on so
that's one thing we have to be careful
and that's a very important thing to
make sure that the regulated entities
any have in mind retail banking
insurance companies pension funds not be
too much exposed to counterparty risk
and that's something from institutions
which themselves are not regulated so
that's something that we had forgotten
or ignored before the crisis and that's
why for example an institution like AIG
which was Rihan investment bank had to
be rescued because otherwise I would
have been turmoil in the markets because
the counterparties would have been in
trouble then so it's very important to
think about the regulation
regulation and this is a scene that I've
been developing with many other
colleagues of course that's not only me
it's a complex subject because it has to
be light enough so that it doesn't kill
entrepreneurship and you know it gives
rise to do a lot of efficiency by the
same time you need to have a strong
state which is going to enforce those
regulation and in an intelligent way so
it's a kind of difficult thing of having
a both light regulation by the same time
some very integral regulation which in
particular is going to intervene early
enough when the bank is doing wrong
things so it has to be very careful in
its provision okay thank you very much I
think we have a final question there
professor general cover once again
congratulations on your prize my name is
youngstrom from TV for I have a question
regarding monopolies and lickable Elise
usually when they're studied you're
looking at nation station but
increasingly globalized world is
research and also policies from example
for example the European Union keeping
pace with increasingly globalized
companies that's correct and what you
see more and more and i think is a good
thing is more and more child work
between competition authorities so even
so the laws are not quite the same in
the US and Europe for example there's a
lot of collaboration between the
Department of Justice for example of the
FTC in the US and the European
Commission competition Directorate and
that's very important you know you have
a wealth mention of Google there are
lots of other
auntie tuition our multinational so it's
they are to regulate without
coordinating in a sense so that's true
fun to try so sorry that's true also for
so banking I mean of course because many
banks now our global I think it's very
good thing for example that in Europe is
in under the job there's a banking Union
in Europe it's it's a very good thing
now we don't know it's going to work
exactly but the idea of having a banking
Union is actually super variety because
it's real create a level playing field
in Europe and also the regulators won't
be the home wrecker a terse which
sometimes can be can be captured as well
and that will take out some of the
political influence out of the
regulatory process that you are
completely right we need global global
instances and I think we are moving to
other local authorities we are moving
toward that in the case of antitrust we
are not yet there for climate change
which is which is a real political prime
modern economic one but that's you're
completely right yes okay thank you very
much so I think that's where the
questions and thank you very much and
looking forward to see you in Des local
in December congratulations again where
I'm thank you very much i'm very
grateful how Marie very grateful thank
you very much ok ok hey do we have any
questions to the panel of experts here
if not a like to end you have placed one
question there you will get a microphone
they were you seen the doc consoles that
I'm slogan I've in fact just holler
warfare a monopole illegal pool and so
Vic Tafur got police a chromatic a lot
to her heart problems from soliton
Martin's economy invalid long did can
you figure pack anatomy on Valley as
some practice in practice govardhan your
Tiryns for things evictee members for
their yeah so the question was why
manopoly monopolies and oligopolies
they've been around for such a long time
so why why give a prize to research on
that topic now and I think one answer so
maybe not the best but one answer to
that is that our added grasp of this
subject is so much better so if you go
back to the last time a price was
awarded in roughly this field in 1982 to
George Stigler that was before a game
theory had taken over the field and if
you look at the literature and I'm sure
George Stigler would have agreed if he
were still alive if you look at all the
things that we've learned from 1992
actually the year after shantal defended
his dissertation and and today and I
think it's fair to say we've learned
more about imperfect competition in that
time span then we learned up until
nineteen eighty-two maybe if I can can
add to that so what tour is saying that
you know there was a major break
breakthrough in using game theory and
contract theory to analyze these
complicated issues which is sort of on
the on the researcher side at the same
time there was a much greater demand for
knowledge about how to regulate in the
mid 1980s where as you remember many
nations started to deregulate previous
natural monopolies such as
telecommunications power companies etc
the European Union started the single
market so issues about regulation and
competition policy at the European level
very much came to the forefront and sort
of the meeting of the sort of
methodology to to answer these questions
under demand from the public of what to
do is really what spurred on this wave
of research that gentil role has led
from the very beginning reference was to
reform them in Rome be just the
political organizer in the myriad higley
animal finance mark not if it doesn't we
can denounce crease like a technique
we've been English to one the most
important political questions today and
he uses how to regulate the financial
market to avoid new financial crisis so
my question is in what way is this a
political price this time I think it not
to a very large extent I think that what
Shanti role is doing is much more like
engineering so of course it's
politicians who decide what the bridge
is to be building and and give
priorities to to trade-offs between you
know the size and the magnitude of the
bridge and the safety and so on and so
forth so they high so politicians will
have to give economists their goals but
given those goals regulation theory is
well suited to work out what is the best
regulation under those goals I think yes
I think to a relatively small degree is
is this
political price okay thank you very much
then then I think we should close this
press conference and I want you all
welcome to two the seventh of December
during the Nobel week when all the lords
in physics chemistry and economic
sciences will meet the press here at the
academy so well then and thank you for
your attention